[Music]
[Applause]
all right the game has just begun which
means we're about 20 minutes away from
all of the urinals being filled with
vomited sangria this man has come from
as far as Minister eyes but this man has
come from as far as Brooklyn Heights
somewhere an artisanal cheese shop has
been left unattended for the World Cup
in Brazil
so you saw the opener you know in
Britain for five bucks you can see
anyone's opener
just to show you how wrong I am to
resent this
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
zero zero
exciting stopping
cheering they're actually dawning at the
top of their lungs
I got a split I'm sorry if I want to
watch a bunch of dudes juggle balls for
two hours I'll go to one of Andy Dick's
pool party Andy Dick
Joyce
jumpin testicles
very exciting as soccer always ease but
now we're getting late in the game in
Mexico has only three brides left
[Applause]
okay in the interests of international
solidarity I pledge to bang a dog from
every country in the world yes
[Applause]
oh yes yes it was a good game
the whole Brazil to a tie is nothing to
be ashamed seriously okay
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
wait are you Boston Terriers Alda tell
me right back okay
Graci Graci o'hare Brazil Brazil did you
finish it let me know when you go am i
doing something wrong
that was a game that was a game man this
is a good time who needs to be in Rio
for the World Cup man you got your beer
you got everything you need right here
in a story of Queens
why would anyone need to go to Rio what
could it possibly have that this doesn't
have
[Music]
excuse me can you tell me where the ass
is as a team or at cemente
badonkadonk Issa
[Applause]
[Music]
ah
[Music]
I love you
you
[Applause]
you